[Musique]
quel bonheur de vous retrouver sur
Public Sénat et pour parler de
littérature avec Thomas Gunzig bonjour
Thomas requis dernier rivage le titre
est magnifique c'est au diable Vau ver
vous avez écrit des uvres de théâtre
vous travaillez à l' RTBF vous êtes
scénariste récompensé avec Yacob vormel
et d'ailleurs votre partenaire
cinématographique a déjà acheté si les
renseignements sont bons C exceptionnel
livre qui s'appelle Rocky dernier rivage
que Gaspard pig a lu hier et il en a
fait d'ailleurs des cauchemars avant
d'arriver à
l'émission car ce livre est phénoménal
Gaspar aussi a écrit un livre phénoménal
ce n'est pas la flagornerie de le dire
nous sommes entre Welbeck et Balzac
Gaspar a
reconstitué pour votre plus grand
plaisir ce que peut-être ce qu'on
appelle une
une utopie pour prendre un mot un peu
pompeux terrifiante autour de jeune
types extrêmement sympathique hyper
brillant qui décide de faire la gros qui
évidemment comme vous tous et comme
nous-même craignons considérablement la
catastrophe écologique sauf que à
vouloir réparer le monde ils le
détruisent et vous allez voir que
l'ironie d'être au Sénat est assez
particulière avec Gaspar car la fin du
livre le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il se passe quelque chose pas très
loin d'ici qui n'est pas très
réjouissant Thomas nous commençons avec
vous je le disais vous êtes à la fois
romancier scénariste et donc ce requis
dernier rivage c'est l'histoire d'une
famille alors fred est un type c'est
c'est un riche antipathique et
sympathique il est sympathique parce que
ça sa grande obsession c'est de sauver
sa famille il a à peu près 40 ans il a
monté avec deux amis une entreprise de
Data dans l'automobile qui marche super
bien et il décide d'arrêter tout de ne
pas collaborer avec l'entreprise de
Zuckerberg de prendre 100 millions
d'euros et sentant que le monde dérape
de trouver une petite île qu'on va
imaginer je résume au large des assorts
dans un endroit où il y a pas de
turbulence le climat est relativement
tranquille équilibré à l'année là il
fait construire une maison magnifique il
installe farci de disque dur d'Internet
de 20 de 60000 repas enfin tout pour la
survie et il emmène sa femme Hélène ses
enfants avec lui et un couple donc c'est
le c'est c'est le départ de l'histoire
et et et un couple qui va travailler
avec eux qui est un couple de chilien
absolument charmant pourquoi avez-vous
décider de raconter cette histoire qui
est une reinonade mais je dirais plus
une sorte de conte à la Swift alors je
sais pas du tout si on décide un moment
de raconter une histoire plutôt qu'un
qu'une
autre je crois que un moment dans dans
un parcours d'auteur peut-être que
Gaspar sera d'accord ou pas avec moi
mais on tombe amoureux d'une idée vous
êtes saisi d'une idée qui vous vient
Dieu Dieu sa où et ce qui est
intéressant avec une idée c'est que pour
qu'une idée vous séduise il faut qu'on
sentre qu'elle va qu'elle est porteuse
d'une histoire qui sera bonne h et je me
suis dit que raconter l'histoire d'une
famille qui est depuis 5 ans sur une île
et que c'est la dernière famille du
monde parce que le monde a disparu mais
que tous les problèmes de subsistance
les problèmes matériels de subsistance
sont réglés parce qu'ils ont une belle
maison au niveau énergétique ils sont
indépendants ils ont tous les repas
qu'il faut il a tout prévu il a tout
c'est un type qui est un ingénieur dans
une famille rationnelle avec une maman
qui malheureusement a été victime d'un
AVC et lui son obsession peut-être en
hommage au père c'est justement de tout
prévoir à 40 ans pour sauver sa famille
de la catastrophe voilà peut-être que
c'est un peu ma propre version version
version riche quoi c'estàd que il est un
peu obsédé il est un peu parano il est
un peu angoissé à l'idée que sa famille
soit en danger donc il est en mode il
faut que je mette ma famille à l'abri et
c'est vrai que dans un monde un petit
peu compliqué comme le NRE autre
c'està-dire le même que celui de Fred
euh la chose la plus raisonnable à faire
c'est se construire une belle maison sur
une île isolée et bien bien équipé voilà
alors ce qui était intéressant
effectivement c'est de faire commencer
l'histoire 5 ans après la fin du monde
c'est-à-dire voir comment ont évolué les
rapports humains euh en particulier les
rapports intrafamiliaux effectivement
comment des ados qui avaient 11 ou 12
ans et qui sont plus grand forcément ils
ont 5 an plus qui sont devenus pub qui
sont donc en proie au tourment des
hormones comment est-ce qu'il voit le
monde euh ils savent qu'ils n'auront
jamais d'histoire d'amour qu' n'auront
jamais d'histoire de sexe comment est-ce
que ça vit un ado comme ça qu'est-ce que
comment vit un couple qui sait qu'il est
le dernier couple alors que c'est un
couple qui n'allait pas forcément très
bien au départ mais que toutes les
lignes de fuite n'existent plus on ne
peut plus être distrait par son travail
par des aventures extraconjugales ou des
choses comme ça c'est le dernier couple
donc j'avais vraiment envie euh de
résumer la famille à sa plus simple
expression et puis un moment de faire
effectivement disparaître la culture
pour se demander on a on a mis parce
qu'on s'est inspiré du film de baslurman
sur gatville magnifique et on donne à
l'écran vous savez dans Gatsby baslurman
donne des phrases de Scott fitgéral ben
là nous ne sommes pas avec Scott
fitgéral mais on est avec Thomas à peu
de chos près il devait faire partie des
derniers humains et jamais il ne
quitterait cette c'est qu'au départ et
c'est ça qui est passionnant on peut se
dire que cette famille se dit que le
monde ne va pas totalement dérailler qui
ne vont pas connaissant l'actualité
d'aujourd'hui sé tripé être victime de
la fl
ce virus qui vient puisque vous le
décrivez très bien d'une partie de la
Russie à 3 ou 4000 km de Moscou les
tensions sociales les tensions ethniques
c'est la catastrophe totale mais au
début ce n'est pas une certitude il y a
cette idée que peut-être ils reviendront
et puis tout d'un coup paf c'est la
panne totale plus rien n'est possible
oui c'est ça c'està dire que quand il se
réfugi sur cette
île ils se disent que c'est pour un
temps donné que les les choses finiront
par se régler parce qu'elles sont
toujours réglées jusqu'à présent donc il
n'envisageait pas effectivement que ça
allait être la fin totale qu'ils
allaient gros coup de chance ou de
malchance pour eux être les les les
derniers et effectivement vous parlez de
d'une panne total c'est-à-dire qu'ils
avaient quand même prévu pour occuper
les longues heures de solitude et
d'ennui d'avoir tous les films du monde
tous les romans du monde toute la
musique du monde mais que là suite à une
éruption solaire et donc à une AORE
boréale qui provoque des des problèmes
électromagnétiques tous les disques durs
sont effacés et donc toute la culture
mondiale qui était en fait la dernière
qui qu'ils avaient avec eux disparaît
aussi sauf un film voilà et et alors il
y a un aspect dans le livre de Thomas
qui est un aspect c'est pour ça que vous
allez aimé qui est profondément
satirique c'estàd que la jeune femme
elle considère qu'elle est absolument
ravissante et que quand elle reviendra
sur terre je parle de la fille elle
séduira tous les hommes elle est accro
aux séries et puis tout d'un coup paf
euh tout bug et elle ne peut plus voir
sa sééie préférée sa mère Hélène qui
adorait son mari tout en ayant la
nostalgie d'un Grec avec une énorme
sexe finit par se masturber en regardant
Titanic donc on est vraiment dans dans
une sorte de cauchemar total de fin de
vie lui boit des Bordeaux de plus en
plus raffinés au bord de la plage mais
il est de plus en plus dépressif il se
laisse aller même c'estik foutent le
camp à force de marcher sur cette petite
île qui fait 5 en m de long ouais il
faut dire que le bordeaux qui boit c'est
le dernier Bordeaux et que les Nikes
avec lesquelle il marche sont les
derniers Nikes voilà et arrive donc
c'est ça qui est formidable parce que
vous avez beaucoup travaillé sur
l'aspect informatique parce que tout ça
a été conçu et on en reparlera parce que
c'est aussi présent la technologie dans
le livre de Gaspard à un moment tout bug
et lui qui est ingénieur il essaie de
tout faire remarcher et il y a une page
remarquable qui est du côté de la page
156 il ma mémoire est bonne où
finalement la réponse euh de
l'ordinateur central qui est gardé dans
son bureau la seule réponse la seule
chose qui reste c'est Rocky ouais ouais
effectivement euh j'avais envie
effectivement que l'effacement global de
tout ce qui relève de la culture euh
soit sauvé par le relicat d'une seule
trace culturelle et que ça soit Rocky
alors pourquoi Rocky alors je me suis là
j'ai
j'avais préparé j'ai essayé de me la
jouer un peu philosophe et j'avais
préparé quelques arguments intelligents
comm Gaspar voilà exactement donc j'ai
lu un peu des essais sur Rocky
sociologique historique et cetera ce que
ce film peut dire sur l'Amérique des
années
70 par exemple et finalement je me suis
dit que tout ça j'allais le laisser
tomber et j'allais essayer d'être
honnête pour une fois et j'ai laissé
roki parce que je pense que c'est mon
film préféré c'est un film dans lequel
je pleure systématiquement c'est un film
que j'adore et je me suis dit que
c'était intéressant de mettre ça au
centre de ce livre il n'y a rien de plus
ridicule qu'un présentateur de
télévision qui vous lit des œuvres qu'il
faut lire car si nous avons choisi ces
livres c'est parce qu'ils sont
absolument passionnant c'était le début
de l'après-midi alors Fred répare
personne ne l'aide à réparer quoi que ce
soit il y a cette horror Béal c'était
début de l'après-midi est là avec son
mac Fred ouvrit le dossier il était vide
presque vide là où aurait dû se trouver
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de films
d'épisodes de séries télévisé d'album de
musique et d'ebook il n'y avait plus
qu'un seul fichier un seul et unique
fichier un unique survivant du
cataclysme audiovisuel littéraire
provoqué par les particules de
l'éruption solaire je vous dis le livre
va vous passionner ce fichier était un
film un film en version originaley je
mets le ton comme à l'école sous-titré
au format vidéo alors là c'est là où
franchement Thomas est gonflé
MKV
barh225 1080p et dont le format audio
était Dolby stéo ce film c'était Rocky
euh ce qui est passionnant dans le livre
je dis ça plusieurs fois mais c'est que
euh n'écartez pas l'idée d'un massacre
il y en aura un N n'écartez pas l'idée
d'une évasion ou d'une tentative
d'évasion il y en aura une c'estàdire
que dans ce petit Hylo il va se passer
énormément de choses alors qu'il sont
totalement enfermé depuis 5 ans et ça
c'est tout le le talent de Thomas qui
est à la fois romancier euh je le disais
scénariste on en parlera tout à l'heure
et qui travaille avec Jacob vonormel ils
ont été récompensés à plusieurs reprises
il écrit des nouvelles il travaille à la
radio c'est publié au diable V vert je
ne vais pas en raconter plus parce que
si j'en raconte plus je dévoile le livre
et ça n'a strictement aucun intérêt et
nous sommes ravis que vous soyez là et
vous partagez cette émission avec Gaspar
qui lui aussi publie un un un autre
livre passionnant aux édition de
l'Observatoire qui s'appelle humus on va
pouvoir échanger tout à l'heure parce
qu'il y a entre vous deux quand même
quelque chose de très commun c'est cette
idée de la catastrophe alors donc nous
sommes avec Arthur qui est un fils de
bourgeois Gaspar et Kevin qui ne
ressemble pas à tous les Kevin ça ça m'a
fait marrer connaissant Gaspard depuis
un certain nombre d'années d'aller
chercher donc quelqu'un qui vient d'un
milieu modeste qui s'appellerait Kevin
mais qui ne serait pas un Kevin qui
réussit toutes les études possibles
imaginables en faisant un effort limité
et qui se retrouve avec celui qui est
une sorte de normalien mais qui refuse
normal parce qu'il trouvent que ce sont
des vuf qui font de la philo ils veulent
aller à agro pour changer le monde parce
qu'ils ont trouvé ou en tout cas ils
sont d'accord après une conférence d'un
professeur qui s'appelle Marcel combe et
après je m'arrête c'est Gaspard qui
raconte ils ils finissent dans un amphi
par percevoir l'un et l'autre ce ce
vieux savant d'une manière différente
Arthur le trouve détestable Kevin le
trouve formidable et il se dit cette
fois-ci le monde fonctionnant sur le
verre de terre nous allons changer le
monde à partir du verre de terre et
c'est comme ça que commence l'aventure
de d'Arthur et de Kevin oui je voulais
faire un un roman d'apprentissage du 21e
siècle c'était ça le le but que j'avais
en tête et autant au 19e siècle on donne
aux héros des objectifs tels que la
gloire militaire l'amour l'argent et
puis après on les plonge dans le réel et
on regarde ce que ça donne autant il est
assez logique aujourd'hui de leur mettre
en tête des idéaux écologiques h et et
donc j'avais besoin pour ça d'un d'un
terreau et ce Terrero je l'ai trouvé
avec le verre de terre alors pareil un
peu par hasard c'est vrai les idées
germes je j'avais ce projet de roman et
puis je faisais mon potager je regarde
des ver de terre je commence à me
documenter ce ver de terre et puis un
jour en me réveillant je met les deux
ensemble h euh et bah le verre de terre
c'est tout à fait fascinant puisque
j'aiécrivais la terre c'est du lombmque
c'est-à-dire du caca de verre de terre
oui c'est le ver de terre est un pharaon
c'est Darwin qui c'est Darwin qui le dit
c'est Darwin qui le premier a écrit a
compris le rôle du verre de terre comme
la boureur de la terre d'ailleurs il a
il a passé des années entières beaucoup
plus de temps que son voyage sur le
Bagle à à faire des expérimentations sur
les vers de terre chez lui et il a
compris que son ver de TER il y a pas de
vie parce qu'en fait le verre de terre
c'est le le sol avec les champignons les
microbactéries et le sol c'est ce qui
transforme la mort en vie les feuilles
mortes tombent sur la terre les cadavres
d'animaux se décomposent et puis tout ça
est est digéré par le sol qui est un
organisme formidablement vivant avec des
millions d'êtres vivant et puis ça donne
des nutriments qui nourrissent les
plantes et cetera et ce sol on le
regarde assez peu au fond on regarde
toujours les étoiles ça fait 3000 ans
que l'humanité regarde les étoiles à des
des astronautes des télescopes prévoir
les trajectoires des comes en revanche
la pédologie la science du sol ce qui
est sous nos pieds elle est elle est
quand même pas très pas très valorisée
pas très
connui l'occasion de bah de montrer ça
et à partir de ça que ces deux héros se
projettent chacun dans je vais sauver le
monde avec le verre de terre mais dans
deux voix très différentes l'un
Kevin prénom auquel ce livre tente de
donner ses lettres de noblesse
littéraires se dit bah enfin se laisse
entraîner vers le capitalisme vert les
start-ups les investissements la tech et
cetera les young leaders de l'humanité
les young leaders qui disent voilà les
vers de terre onont sauvé le monde et
qui font des conférences sur le sujet et
pourquoi pas et l'autre Arthur se laisse
entraîner lui bah loin de son milieu
aussi mais plus vers la terre le retour
à la terre la normand qu'on appelle la
Suisse Normande exactement une
entreprise de famille enfin une vieille
ferme de famille vieille ferme de son
grand-père qui avait qui est dévasté
dont le sol a été dévasté par l'abus de
pesticidees d'intan chimique et que
Arthur va essayer de régénérer d'abord
en faisant une et puis petit à petit en
se radicalisant en se politisant et
d'ailleurs la Suisse Normande je la
partage alors moi j'y vis en grande
partie et puis je la partage aussi avec
Welbeck qui la met en scène dans
sérotonine pour revenir au dé c'est la
raison pour laquelle je voulais en
arriver à cette question c'est qu'il y a
chez vous Gaspard quelque chose qui est
un mélange que wbec d'ailleurs
revendique c'estàdire welbeco balsatien
c'estàd qu'on part de cette idée des ver
de terre mais là c'est vraiment une
aventure type illusion perdu de deux
jeunes gens qui partent à la conquête du
monde chacun de leur côté avec chacun
leur utopie alors il y a des scènes
hilarantes puisque l'un des personnages
que nous avavons pas encore évoqué alors
il y a Anne qui est la petite
amie d'Arthur et en plus ils font la
rencontre en tout cas Kevin du dénommé
philippine qui est un des personnages
que je préfère dans le roman de Gaspar
parce que c'est c'est la cynique absolue
c'est qu'elle rencontre c'est surtout
Kevin et elle le transforme en machine à
lever des fonds alors que lui au fond il
est il a envie de monter sa boîte mais
c'est pas un assassin alors qu'elle
c'est absolument ça complètement mais
d'abord il me fallait ce personnage un
pour montrer que dans cette génération
bah il y a beaucoup de gens qui veulent
sauver le monde mais il y en a qui onont
absolument rien à faire qui sont des
tartufes absolues mais qui se disent je
vais me mettre dans dans le sillon et
puis je vais faire de la mousse avec ça
tellement envie de citer des noms mais
je retiens mais Philippines on peut
citer un nom puisque le personnage est
modelé sur Elizabeth Holmes qui avait
fondé la start-up terranos qui a été une
immense fraude aux États-Unis il y a
quelques années qui est maintenant en
prison d'ailleurs j'ai vraiment pris ce
ce modèle à partir du livre bad blood
d'un journaliste qui s'appelle carero je
signale et jeallis continer parce que
c'est pas une façon de vous interrompre
mais pour recommander au lecteur la
manière dont philippin emmène Kevin en
Californie vous allez voir et quand vous
lirez ça Thomas vous allez adorer ils
vont dans des grandes boîtes
californiennes rencontrer des types qui
sont dans des endroits somptueux et qui
écoutent leur pitch pour savoir s'ils
vont lever des fonds et leur rapporter
de l'argent c'est hilarant du début
jusqu'à la fin parce que c'est une
comédie en fait c'est du lubit tout le
monde ment alors oui et donc j'ai voulu
d'abord comme chacun des héros voit le
monde un milieu disons qui lui est
inconnu c'est un peu les deux candides
les deux Hurons et donc on peut à partir
de ça construire beaucoup d'ironies
beaucoup d'humour parce qu'il découvre
les choses et le lecteur les découvre
avec eux et puis ce que j'ai voulu faire
aussi c'est vraiment construire un roman
très réaliste disait balsacien voilà et
donc je me suis vraiment documenté à la
fois sur les vers de terre mais aussi
sur ces toutes ces ces scènes qui sont
décrites sur par exemple euh l'endroit
don que vous mentionnez à Palo Alto où
j'ai été j'ai vu ces baraques là c'est
d'ailleurs pas du tout hein les les gras
de ciel en vert avec les gens en costume
hein c'est tout l'inverse la la le vrai
argent il est à euh quasiment dans la
nature dans les forêts de seoya dans des
maisons qui font deux étages des fonds
d'investissement qui ont qui embauchent
juste quelques dizaines de personnes qui
sont hyper cool qui sont jeans et en
T-shirt ouis sauf qu'ils ont les
tableaux sublimes sur les murs que les
maisons sont extraordinaires ils sont
tous bouddhistes enfin voilà donc c'est
j'ai aussi voulu montrer le capitalisme
contemporain dans ce qu'il a de d'assez
différent du capitalisme industriel du
20e siècle et de avec ses vertus ces vis
euh et et l'idée aussi queil suffit de
faire un bon pitch de raconter une belle
histoire pour lever de l'argent donc on
est on est dans un monde qui en fait
n'est pas du tout rationnel et Kevin est
effectivement instrumentalisé par
Philippines alors Philippines elle est
complètement cynique parce que du coup
elle dit la vérité des choses ça c'est
très agréable je pense pour le lecteur h
euh et puis
euh ça ça ça ça permet à à Kevin de lui
lui sont il est il vient d'un milieu
populaire modeste mais il s'en fout de
l'histoire de transfug de classe et
cetera lui il se laisse un peu porter
par la vie c'est pour ça que j'adore
d'ailleurs ce personnage c'est un
vagabond solaire mais en fait philippine
l'instrumentalist en disant non non on
va jouer le transfuge de classe parce
que c'est ça qu'on attend de toi elle
elle s'en rend compte à un moment donné
c'est un personnage horrible quoi en
fait toute cette élite
politico-économique elle a besoin de
celui qui ne vient pas d'elle pour
s'autojustifier voilà faut dire regardez
regardez on n'est pas seulement entre
nous regardez bah il y a Kevin euh à
chaque fois qu'on leur propose une
réforme intelligente il bloque le pays
ça c'est dans une réunion des young
leaders qu'il arrive Kevin al il y a
Thomas pesqu enfin il y a tous les
jeunes dont on parle qui réussissent et
cetera évidemment il h contre les
manifestations il hurle contre la grève
à un moment il y a une phase qui m'a
beaucoup fait rire il a choisi un
nouveau p pays qui porte ces magnifi
couleurs qui sont celles d' chaussé
parce que quand il a fait AG gros
évidemment il est quand même très
conscient qu'il faut qu'il passe le
stade supérieur en matière j'allais dire
de baratin et donc il va achuser faire
un de la même manière que le vôtre a
fait un un NBA et bien lui va a chuser
pour essayer d'étayer son histoire alors
la grande différence entre les deux
parce qu'il faut aussi que ça participe
d'une conversation je répète ce sont de
romans excellents et qui vont beaucoup
vous plaire c'est que Thomas vous
apporter une c certaine forme d'espoir
alors que le le jeune Kenig que vous
voyez ici qui qui a apporté à la fin de
son livre c'est très amusant qu'on soit
sur Public Sénat euh une vision de la
fin qui est digne d'un film de pinkina
c'est-à-dire c'est vraiment Riot gun ils
se sont tous radicalisés que ce soit les
fabricants entreprise ou les jeunes
comme Arthur qui essayent mais
n'arrivent pas à réformer le le monde
agricole et il ils deviennent des des
des tegevaras du verre euh ils s'armment
jusqu'aux dents et on va vous le dire
hein prenez votre temps ils attaquent le
Sénat armé jusqu'aux dents avec euh
toutes les forces de l'ordre qui
essayent de s'y opposer donc pourquoi
ces choses différentes alors dans mon
cas moi ça fait euh peut-être 30 ans que
j'écris des romans qui finissent
toujours très très mal bien déprimant
bien sombre et je me suis dit bon Thomas
à la fin tu t déprime et je me suis dit
peut-être que offrir un peu de lumière à
la fin ça serait pas mal pour toi pour
ton équilibre mental pour le lecteur
voilà voilà j'ai eu j'ai un petit peu
forcé ma nature mais je suis content
d'avoir fait mis un peu de lumière
justement à la fin parce qu'en fait
toute la maison est détruite celle sur
laquelle il vivent et c'est cette île
qui devienent la maison cette île qui
s'approprie et Jeanne qui est la fille
qui est justement une sorte de prototype
de jeune fille sexy au fond elle devient
un peu la romancière de la famille celle
qui leur raconte des contes et c'est
très effectivement en qu ou C pages de
retournement très poétique mais vous
allez voir qu'au milieu du livre il y a
tellement de choses à raconter que ça
vous passionner alors vous c'est du
Tarantino puissance 100 à la fin bon
d'abord à la fin le romancier arrive à
la fin de son roman donc il peut un peu
se lâcher si je peux dire c'est j'ai
tenu toute ma narration pendant 350
pages et puis comme c'est deux points de
vue différents qui alternent il fallait
vraiment être très très rigoureux sur le
déroulé chronologique et donc à la fin
le romancier se lâche un peu aussi pour
tout vous dire et va jusqu'au bout de
son imaginaire et effectivement met en
scène des choses un peu un peu
fantasmagoriques oui sauf que la
question qui est posé la société
française aujourd'hui c'est est-ce que
c'est pas justement ça qui va se passer
d'ailleurs j'ai un sénateur qui m'a
envoyé un texto qui après avoir lu le
livre et qui m'a dit ah bah sympa
l'attaque du Sénat je lui réponds
t'inquiète pas c'est pas toi qui passais
par la fenêtre et il me répond de toute
façon ça va finir comme ça et
effectivement ce que je veux quand même
montrer sur le fond à travers C alors là
on est dans la effectivement un peu dans
la dystopie puisque c'est 10 ans après
disons que là on est en 2030 et en fait
la génération de ceux qui aujourd'hui
font la désobéissance civile donc mes
héros qui 20 ans et rattrapé par la
génération d'après ceux qui sont ados
aujourd'hui qui leur disent mais écoutez
tous vos trucs de se coller sur les
voitures de faire des manifes avec des
chazubles et cetera ça marche pas donc
maintenant on va passer ce qui est assez
logique dans l'histoire des mouvements
politiques au terrorisme au sens SRI he
c'estàd il y a pas de révolution sans
Mor on a vu à caspr récemment qu'une des
jeunes femmes qui manifestait pour
laazade parce qu'on sort notre des
Landes et là il y a eu cette tentative
elle avait un t-shirt d'action direct
c'estàd qu'on revenait 25 ans en arrière
avec des jeunes gens qui au fond euh
revenz à un terrorisme qui est le
terrorisme européen des années des
années 70 je suis beaucoup ces
mouvements là j'ai d'ailleurs grande
sympathie quand même pour au moins pour
leur point de départ euh je fais souvent
la comparaison avec Action Directe
justement en disant on en est pas encore
à action directe mais effectivement
depuis la publication de comment saboter
un un pipeline il y a quelques années on
voit très bien que le mouvement
écologiste se sentant dépasser et
sentant que la désobéissance civile ne
suffit plus et tenter de passer à des
actions qui sont là plus du tout pour
prendre conscience pour convaincre et
CER qui sont là pour prendre le pouvoir
et faire ce qu'il faut faire y compris
par la force et donc là c'est
effectivement le terrorisme d' d'Action
Directe c'estàd le vrai terrorisme
aujourd'hui on n'est pas du tout du tout
du tout dans le dans le terrorisme
contrairement à ce que pense le ministre
de l'Intérieur et donc mais il y a tout
de même la toute fin du livre qui pour
moi n'est pas si différente de celle de
Thomas parce que dans le tout dernier
chapitre après ce ce passage là je pas
tout raconter non mais il y a aussi une
forme alors je vais pas je vais pas la
raconter mais il y a aussi une forme de
réussite je trouve des deux héros qui
échouent dans leurs grands idéaux mais
qui réussissent plus dans les dans les
petites choses qu'ils entreprennent et
au fond la réussite finale c'est que
quelque part la nature reprend le dessus
Tchernobyl aujourd'hui c'est la plus
grande réserve de biodiversité d'Europe
parce que plus personne n'y touche
depuis 40 ans et que les les chevaux de
prevevski reviennent que les arbres ont
craqué séque et puis leur amitié s'est
reconstitué leur amitié s'est
reconstitué dans une terre complètement
dévasté par les pesticides vous la
laissez tranquille pendant 20 ans bah
les vers de terre ils reviennent tout
seul et ça redevient une prairie et de
nouveau vous avez de l'herbe grasse et
donc il y a quand même ce ce un peu ce
message à la fin de peut-être suffit-il
de ne rien faire quelqu temps pour que
la vie reprenne le dessus le livre de
Thomas Gunzig s'appelle Rocky dernier
Riva je le disais c'est un titre
magnifique c'est au diable B Vau vert
Thomas je suis ravi que vous soyez là
parce que au moins vous êtes le premier
bel de cette émission et ce premier
Belge n'est pas Amélie ne tombe ce qui
est une bonne nouvelle vous savez que
vous savez que nous avons le complexe
belge parce que nous avons virginieira
Damien spouvord Yan fabbre dim bevie
enfin on a l'impression qu'on est envahi
par les gens qui sont beaucoup plus
intelligent que nous ben dans votre cas
c'est une réalité ce roman est réussi
Gaspar le livre s'appelle
humus donc et on voit donc deux
personnages à l'abri d'un arbre il y a
une ville en dessous et c'est aux
éditions de l'Observatoire vous allez à
Brive la foire de Brive je sais pas si
vous y allez Thomas pas c année pas c
année pourquoi vous allez à Brive parce
que c'est la plus grande foire française
et nous en sommes partenaires donc nous
en sommes très contents mais c'est une
nécessité d'abord mon éditeur me dit d'
aller moi je fais ce que me dit mon
éditeur en ce moment vous êtes pas un
petit garçon non enfin bon comme là j'ai
vraiment de 3 mois où je fais je passe
mon temps à promouvoir le livre et
quasiment tous les jours j'ai un
déplacement en salon ou en librairie à
la rencontre des lecteurs et c'est c'est
assez formidable de voir des lecteurs de
toutes générations de voir ce qu'ils en
ont pensé évidemment la nouvelle
génération je suis particulièrement
intéressé d'entendre leur réaction et
comme j'ai participé au Tour de France à
du concours des lycéens ça m'a permis
aussi de d'entendre leur son de cloche
donc tout ça ça participe du lancement
du livre après bririv ce qui est
particulièrement sympathique je trouve
dans Brive c'est que comme vous dites
c'est la foire et donc autant dans les
autres salons sont plus disons
raisonnables autant Brive c'est la
fêteou et donc pour finir la saison
c'est pas mal de faire une grande fête
et après je vous promets on se remet au
boulot et on recommence à écrire ouais
al entre temps il y aura les prix
littéraires et mon petit doigt me dit
qu'il n'est pas impossible que Gaspar
obtienne un prix littéraire moi j'ai un
souvenir absolument phénoménal à Brive
euh j'étais avec lespous de Gaston de
fer euh donc oubliez Palerme euh vous
vous souvenez de cette romancière Edmond
charlerou Edmond charlerou et à un
moment j'ai voulu lui parler d'Alain
robgriillet parce que j'aimais beaucoup
Alain robgriet et elle est devenue vert
jaune comme quoi le nouveau ramand avait
été pour elle l'agression absolue de sa
génération euh alors il fait tout notre
ami Thomas notamment avec von dormel et
un autre partenaire et deux autres
partenaires vous avez été les
scénaristes du dernier pharaon de Black
et mortimerire donc vous imaginez donc
la palette de son talent le voici je
vous l'offre
p euh voilà Siri houed vous savez c'est
c'est évidemment la femme de pauloster
enfin évidemment c'est un mot absurde
mais c'est un essai sur la condition
humaine et c'est un très joli livre
parce que très souvent les grands
écrivains américains par exemple Stephen
King à un moment il écrit il écrit il
écrit des romans et puis il a écrit un
livre qui s'appelle écriture pour faire
le point sur tout ce qu'il avait fait et
on est très surpris de la maturité avec
laquelle justement il a abordé toute
cette œuvre et là l'intérêt du livre de
siriustad c'est que non seulement il
s'agit d'écriture mais il s'agit de la
condition humaine et il s'agit aussi de
l'art euh c'est pour ça que nous allons
arriver donc à Nicolas de Stal Nicolas
de Stal vous savez émigré russe qui a
fini sa vie du côté d'antip sur le port
c'est probablement le peintre abstrait
français le plus important à est Tom
moderne de la Ville de Paris tout est
absolument sublime et voici le catalogue
de l'émission puisque nous parlions de
dystopie je voulais parler et je voulais
signaler le livre de Nina Allen qui
s'appelle Conquest euh par l'auteur de
la
fracture 50000 exemplaires vendus c'est
publié donc aux éditions Tristam donc
sirusad et puis l'art de la
guerre c'est donc une aventure de Black
et Mortimer mais c'est la dernière
celle-là donc par floc franental et bet
et puis toujours cette ligne noire que
nous devons évidemment à RG mais que
nous devons aussi à magrit parce que
tout à l'heure j'évoquais avec Thomas ce
qu'on appelle nous bêtement la belgitude
mais c'est vrai que nous devons beaucoup
ayursonard nous devons beaucoup à RG
nous devons énormément à simnon et à
toute une génération donc d'artistes
dans tous les domaines en Belgique que
nous ressentons comme nos vrais frères
d'où votre présence Tomas qui nous a
fait extrêmement plaisir et Gaspar je
souhaite le meilleur dans les jours qui
viennent parce que je sais par
expérience pour avoir vécu un peu la
même chose l'année dernière que quand
les prix
approchent voilà bonne chance à tous les
deux et bonne lecture à vous car
franchement ces deux livres méritent que
vous leur crer un weekend une semaine le
temps que vous voulez mais en tout cas
que vous les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lisiez